prison forces you to step outside of the
box it forces you out of your comfort
zone you don't have an option
you know if i never used to be able to
use public bathrooms i remember one time
in school
i called home sick so i could go use the
toilet
you know and i couldn't use a public
bathroom but
then when you fly into oklahoma which is
usually the beginning of your bid
they fly to oklahoma which is like the
detention center then they decide where
you get designated then you go to where
you're designated from there
pretty crazy right like sentenced in
orlando
you end up in a prison an hour away from
where you're sentenced but you go to
oklahoma first
so weird it's weird but they put you on
that rickety rusty 747 that they stole
from some
con air so you know it's crazy all the
overhead compartment's like
i was like oh no we're gonna die you
know but but uh you know
they put you in a room where there's one
toilet in the middle of the room
no dividers and there's a hundred people
in there so if you have to take a [ __ ]
you have to use that toilet did you ever
do that yeah i mean you don't have an
option
county jail was like that too you know
when i was in county jail you you have
you ha you can hang sheets and stuff and
then the guards yell at you and take to
take it down
yeah but you're taking a shower in front
of everybody you're
you're going number two in front of
everybody you just you know what we
adapt
human beings are highly adaptable you
think you can't do something
but you can do it you know when you have
no choice you have no choice you'll do
it what how did that
how did that taking a [ __ ] in a room
full of people with no barriers
dude it's humiliating it's dehumanizing
doing that compared to
i mean on the flip side for a kid that
never even liked to use public restrooms
what was the
the actual effect on you from doing that
i think it was positive now you know i
no longer have that problem
i'm no longer p shot i can walk up to a
urinal and whip my dick out and take a
piss
you know i can i can use a bathroom
anywhere even if it's dirty i just wipe
it off and lay a toilet cover down and
just do what i got to do
dude if you got to go you got to go and
you know that's
so did it make you more of like like i
mean
did it make you more of an open person
in general does it make you more
extroverted
how else did it affect you yeah i'm
definitely extroverted now
um now i find myself starting
conversations with people i don't even
know
that wasn't me before prison and that's
a very
you know i'm still learning i'm still
getting better at that but that's a very
beneficial thing like getting stuck
in your comfort zone is probably the
most dangerous thing you could do
because you're closing yourself off to
all kinds of potential all kinds of
opportunities
i was just at the mall a couple weeks
ago and i was waiting outside the
bathroom
on my girlfriend and this guy walks up
to me and just starts a conversation
with me and he's like i like your
tattoos where'd you get them i said
federal prison and this guy's you know
he's dressed really nice and i can tell
he's got money
turns out he owns a big packing company
um has
millions of dollars invested in crypto
uh he's doing extremely well now we're
talking on
telegram and you know it's it's just
crazy if you step outside of your
comfort zone and talk to people you're
gonna that's how you make relationships
and you know when i was closed off i
limited myself
so much you know just just so much
i had legitimate business ideas before i
went to prison if i had not
done what was comfortable to me you know
making money easily taking the easy road
not considering who it was hurting or
or you know the negative impacts the
negative consequences that could have
came from it
and just did the right thing you know
believed in myself enough to engage and
talk to investors and sell my idea to
the right people
then money is out there legal money
good money it's out there it's it's out
there in abundance
and i'm learning that now with
contractor plus you know it's
money is available as long as you're
doing right and as long as you can
produce reports
as long as you're tracking your progress
you have a good accountability system
for yourself and for your team
and you can produce reports that show
how accountable you're being and the
progress that you're making
you know it's all about the kpis but
it's readily available we've already
raised 42
000 of a 250 000 seed round that's been
up for less than a month
what are you talking about for
contractor plus what's contractor plus
so contractor plus is a
field service management solution for
its mobile field service management
solution for android and for
iphone and we have a web dashboard it
does
everything from estimating to invoicing
to payments to
to job scheduling it literally helps you
if whether you're a handyman company or
a plumber or an electrician
or a painter it doesn't matter what you
do if you send invoices
if you need if you need to show your if
you if you want to look
good to your clients and you want to win
more business and grow your business
as a field service company contractor
plus helps you and it's totally free you
can go download it for android and
iphone
so we're talking about a guy you met in
the mall uh
yeah so he uh something about masks or
something
oh yeah so he noticed my mask said
um freedom doesn't look like this is
what my mask says
oh and he wasn't wearing a mask in the
mall
and you know of course he was looking
like a million bucks so he looked like
he owned them all
but and maybe that's why he gets away
with it but he said i don't wear a mask
anywhere
and i said well how you know i've tried
walking in places without masking people
tell me to put it on or leave so what do
you say when that happens
he says it's my constitutional right i'm
not putting it on you know then but
i think about it and i'm like wait a
minute though the private property
axiom like the like it like if you own a
business and
you say you don't want people in there
without masks
don't you have a right to do that it's
your business yeah for sure so then
shouldn't people
respect that you know people should
respect if they wanna
eat you're at your restaurant right and
if not they could then i think that's
the way free market capitalism really
regulates itself
is like if you don't wanna go to a place
that's forcing you to our mass then go
somewhere that doesn't
you know that's your choice so you know
i respect
private property right on the street or
driving in your own car
or out in the park or whatever don't
wear it right there's people around
there that aren't wearing masks and you
want to wear your mask then don't
[ __ ] go to the park
exactly right exactly so
you know but that that you're sending a
very clear message with uh
having freedom doesn't look like this on
your mask
yeah it's like it's like the people with
the uh
like you know somebody who has like a
trump mask or like a maga mask
they don't really want to be wearing
that mask they're just uh
they want to they want to wear that that
bumper sticker you know not to get
political or anything but isn't it kind
of crazy i don't think
it's so things are so polarized right
now like you drive in like the rural
areas and everyone still has their trump
signs up
oh yeah around here everywhere around
here like they this is the first
election i feel like people have not
been able to let go of
they just can't oh no just let it go man
oh yeah
let it go yeah people all the time that
just they're always
talking about the fraud in the election
and
voter fraud they destroyed the ballots
i've heard so much more people are more
pissed off about voter fraud this
election i think than ever before it's
never been talked about this much as far
like
in my like i remember when trump got
elected
it was a bunch of problems they've been
claiming fraud every election right
for a while now honestly but it's never
been theater it's never been
oh yeah it's a distraction it is it's
like the wwe but it's never been
it's always been just like no one's been
so attached to the actual
person you know everyone's been like red
or blue
but he's not a politician he's a
businessman but they're so attached to
him it's like
[ __ ] the pollock [ __ ] left or right it's
trump or die
trump or bust you know what i mean he's
such a genius communicator and it's such
a genius marketer
he's really [ __ ] embedded and he
likes to grab women by the [ __ ] hell
yeah he does
why not vote for that by the [ __ ] he uh
he really he knows what the [ __ ] he's
doing that's for sure i have to i have
to hand it to him
but but yeah a lot of people a lot of uh
a lot of people just can't let go of him
you know what i mean they have that
emotional
connection to him i think where i'm at
with it is like
i realize that it's all a bunch of bs
you know it's
it's to me like george carlin actually
one of my favorite comedians
uh the late george carlin yeah he used
to say it's all a bunch of [ __ ] and
it's bad for you
you know and that's what he that's what
he had to say about the government is
totally bad for you
i just see it as as a big lie you know
they put this puppet in office
who's not really making any decisions at
all and that's really what i believe
is that you know the intelligence
community it's way beyo it's way above
that
he's just a puppet it's just a
marionette and he's someone we can blame
all of our problems on
um for four years or eight years and
then we just move on to the next guy
and it's funny because they they keep us
divided left and right between trivial
issues that should not be dividing
mankind
like it's okay if you have a difference
of opinion on something but we should
still be able to shake hands and get
along
and like you know what i mean like we
should not be so divided
over stuff that doesn't matter you know
it's okay that you have a different
opinion than me like the most fun i mean
the hard part about it is all these
[ __ ] companies
all these news uh news companies and
social media platforms everyone who
exists on social media who makes a
living on social media
the only only way for them to generate
traffic and earn income
is to push these hot button topics that
get people riled the [ __ ] up
like these police shootings pick your
side you're going to be red or blue
right here we go put out a [ __ ]
headline and then that's how they earn
their income
those headlines just grab you by the
throat like they force you to pay
attention to it
that's the problem is that that's how a
lot of people make their money online by
by getting those that [ __ ] to go viral
you know what i mean getting those crazy
headlines
that's what people what that's what
attracts people that's what gets clicks
use trigger words evoke emotion high
arousal emotions
that can be good or bad but make them
evoke curiosity
make them have to understand what's
behind that headline yeah
or question that and they're going to
click it and they're going to read
and you know the headline's the most
important part for sure right